want to get the one up and your
opponent's went ultra street fighter 4
launches this June Capcom community
manager and street fighter fro David
Hines gives us his tips and favorite
combos for ultras 5 you characters
here's what he's got to say about the
lens oh alright so what kind of
character is a lenten relent Oh is he's
actually a hit-and-run style querido
you'll see he's got lots of different
movement options and ways of kind of
changing his jump to victory and he can
roll along the floor he's got like a lot
back flip him back fit into the roll
jump off the wall he's already is
amazing movement option he has got some
really nice all combos though so from
Crouching medium cake you can go into as
a patriot circle at match which is this
thing that's a triple attacks you don't
have to all three can just do one do do
you can do two of them by if you see the
hit you can see it hit you can just
continue all the way through to the end
he's also got a projectile move which is
Waitrose the night actually it's kind of
a good jump you don't have to throw it
you can just going to show your opponent
what you're about to do right and then
from here on you can choose when you
throw it that's got a TX version we see
throws three of them out and the great
thing about 80 x version you can use it
in combos ok like that now real enter
has 101 ways of landing his ultra one
okay and the reason they say this is
because it lands pretty much after every
juggle state special move that he's got
so for instance of this one you can add
it after that
just pretty cool Oh nuts
Oh